now the dea is warning that a massive
influx of migrants will lead to a surge
in mass fentanyl overdose events here's
what congressman dan crenshaw had to say
about the fentanyl crisis and the link
to title 42.
say the pandemic's over and then there's
no more argument for title 42. i'll tell
you what there's another argument for
title 42 and that's fentanyl fentanyl is
another public health crisis
canyon county idaho sheriff kieran
donahue joins us now good morning to you
sheriff you just heard the congressman
there say that the fentanyl crisis is a
public health issue and a majority of it
is coming across the southern border so
how is fentanyl affecting your community
well thank you and good morning we're
we're overwhelmed with with fentanyl and
the seizures of fentanyl and of course
overdose accounts here and
these are numbers that we have never
seen before they're literally
unprecedented and literally fentanyl is
at everyone's doorstep because of that
poorest border and because of what the
cartels and how much supply they are
moving across the border the southern
border and of course it's infiltrating
every single community in the united
states
and then sheriff i want to read this
from a dea administrator it's on this
morning it says already this year
numerous mass overdose events have
resulted in dozens of overdose and
deaths now drug traffickers are driving
addiction increasing their profits by
mixing fentanyl with other illicit drugs
tragically many overdose victims have no
idea they are ingesting deadly fentanyl
until it's too late a lot of people are
seeing at least
fentanyl laced with something as
harmless as
marijuana um and just a little bit of
this goes a long way so now when title
42 ends we're already seeing a huge
influx of it what what are the sheriff's
departments gonna do um because even
trace amounts can affect them and then
they get put out of service so is it
going to be a situation where you have
to have extra narcan on hand have you
guys prepared for that
well
yes actually we already we're already
doing that we're already in a situation
where we're carrying narcan in all of
our cars we're carrying narcan or having
narcan in our jails and we're actually
dispensing narcan routinely even in the
jails when they come into contact with
searching a person at the jail we've had
deputies literally be go down have
narcan administered sending deputies to
the to the hospital to save their lives
we've already seen this now with this
with this surge and with the again
overwhelming amount and you you
mentioned how the cartels the business
model for them is to we don't care how
many people are dying we're going to
advance and increase our consumer base
and that's their their business model
and so they are flooding as you say with
with a
product that and these are unsuspecting
uh doses of that people are taking think
they may be taking cocaine crack cocaine
methamphetamine or as you mentioned
marijuana but it's not it's laced with
with
fentanyl or it's actual fentanyl and
taking the place of cocaine and other
substances and these people as you as
you know we've lost 105 000 people last
year to overdose 66 of those were can be
attributed to fentanyl those are
astounding and terrifying numbers in in
this country and we are bracing for
what's going to happen next yeah i think
that that statement from the dea is
stunning because the president's own dea
is admitting that this is a public
health crisis and it starts at the
border and yet there is no push to
change the policies to fix this
what's your message to the president
this is unacceptable and the president
needs to take responsibility and the
administration needs to assist
our colleagues on the border customs and
border protection the board of sheriffs
this this is something that we cannot
sustain in this country and it's
certainly going to affect as i've
mentioned every single community every
single household you've got children
dying of fentanyl overdose you've got
these mass overdose events that you
noted in the dea
press release the president must it's
not it's not he should he must do
something to stop
this this scourge and i'm telling you
i've said this many times even on on fox
we have to take this battle to the
cartels we cannot wait for president
biden he's certainly not going to help
us and we must do something on that
board to stop the cartels and the influx
of of this enormity of illegal
substances like fentanyl that are
killing americans yeah
behind every single fentanyl pill there
is a member of a mexican cartel that's
making money and right now they're
winning that can't happen sheriff karen
donahue thank you so much for joining us
this morning we appreciate it best of
luck
thank you
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now